[Musique]
elles font la joie des petits et des
grands les trempettes sont populaires
n'offrent en épicerie le démontre au
delà de 14 marques
une quarantaine de produits analysés
pour eve crépeau nutritionnistes des
produits faits à partir de ce décret mme
souad huile de mayonnaise de hyogo de
hyogo grecs même maintenant de babar
bref il ya plusieurs types de base c'est
assez impressionnant la variété qu'on
retrouve qu'est-ce que je dois chercher
sur une étiquette qu'est ce que je
regarde pour faire un choix avant un
goûter à première vue le cialis de
grézan femmes courent que tu es
d'ingrédients pizza dit quelque chose je
te connais un peu le rôle de chaque
ingrédient c'était bon signe
tout au contraire tu tombes sur une
trempette comme ça où est ce cas là les
ingrédients déjà ici un tout petit parce
que c'est tellement long qu'il ya plein
de choses à te sais pas trop à quoi ça
sert mouassa matière - ensuite je
regarderai au niveau du sodium parce que
le ciel ça reste un des principaux
problèmes des produits transformés 75%
notre apport quotidien en ciel vient des
produits transformés donc décidé de
réduire le plus possible les marques
lighthouse le grec et philadelphia ondes
et tout ce diom alors de 200 à 280 mg
par portion les grands gagnants au
deutsch avec 300 mg de sodium donc 13%
pour de carrasso c'est énorme ça ça va
vite pis old dutch une compagnie de type
donc c'est comment je la mange plus avec
des types qui avec des carottes
siewiller peut-être donc encore plus de
sel
c'est quoi la cance étudiants qu'on
devrait visiter pas une cible voulue de
se dire moi je devais toujours le moins
possible le moins possible puis le moins
possible ont trouvé chez sommer frêche
qui était à 40 60 mg de sodium par
portion était vraiment celui qui se
distinguait les outils sont autour de st
dans ce coin là mais vraiment sur le
fait chez ceux qui étaient vraiment les
plus faibles en ce dieu l'elliptique aux
moqueries tas principal parti quand je
prends une trompette crémeuse à base de
mayonnaise matin à cannes est délicate
et de préférer souvent prendre une
trempette qui est vraiment faite à base
de mayonnaise qui repousse devant le
plein d'âme non de maïté texturants pour
réduire le g et d'en prendre un peu
moins c'est de faire attention à la
quantité mais de prendre un produit qui
justement se rapproche de ce que je
ferai à la maison à base de mayonnaise
des crèmes sur ou de hyogo
souvent c'est des trucs comme déjà dans
notre frigo puis tant qu'on l'ait fait
qu'est ce que les fans aussi c'est de
trempettes qu'on peut faire mais qui
vont regarder aussi 9,5 à ce jour au
réfrigérateur
isabelle plante nous propose trois
trempette simples et savoureuses pour
une fraction du prix est prêt à manger
en quelques minutes une traditionnelle
range à base de crème sur une audacieuse
ou you go et à la betterave puis une
trempette aux épinards et ricotta ont
ils veulent et j'ai aussi un sel puis
comparé à ce qu'on trouve parfois on est
free agent de conservation de danse et
des âmes fragiles acquis tout des bons à
nîmes avec même si un petit peu de
matières grasses
je pense qu'on peut vivre mais compris
commencer par là la trompette ça va
prendre mathématiquement on rajoute ans
et de la pologne puis la peau d'âne qui
va donner le goût caractéristique de la
fameuse trempé trench on aurait pu se
mettre de l'ail frais haché mais 60e
toujours dans le garde manger
pourquoi pas l'exposer dans la trempette
ensuite des herbes fraîches et j en veux
m et si estragon puis planète qu'on va
lâcher pense et rapporte un peu là
c'était juste rend tout simplement qui
est pour lui tout seul ça sent bon les
ernst rang on y va ensuite avec la
trompette ou you go et à la betterave un
mariage audacieux mais aussi succulents
que colorés
j'y allais avec le fameux gourde 10% on
peut y aller c'est là que yugo briques
et leur effort qui va apporter un peu de
piquant beaucoup de planches à notre
trempette
ensuite cette fois sans utiliser les est
de les réguler ensuite en venir sur ce
régime de m libre puis une people
maintenant on est ici on trouve déjà des
betteraves cuites
on la passe dans notre bouquet final une
belle purée mais on préfère une plus
vigoureuse à mélanger un peu le cargo
c'est ça aussi et avec la cuillère on
venait juste marre blé pour sa phase et
j'ai lu qu'on me dise mettre un peu
d'huile d'olive comme ça puis je n'ai
acheté mais ça c'est vraiment facultatif
du match ça va porter aussi une acidité
puis pour lui il savait vraiment julie
accéder pour une deuxième trempe et la
plus compliquée pas qu'un peu
et pour varier une trempette aux
épinards à base de fromage ricotta
c'est un fromage qu'on va pas pensé
prendre pour faire détrempée mais c'est
quelque chose qui est à peu près sans
fraîcheur avec la récolte les pesto je
les ai rajouté pour apporter
on aurait pu aussi mettre des herbes à
l'intérieur ou une veste aux maîtres des
feuilles de basilic persil jeudi seront
encore une fois mais c'est ça la beauté
des recettes ou les tremper real c'était
pour une trempette c'est pas de la
partie mais quand vous y allez allez y
puis à vous comme la pour les piments et
jamais une par une bonne pincée on
aurait pu aussi mettre du poids puis un
petit peu c'est elle pour finir on va
juste ni acheté une petite hache on a un
beau plateau coloré prime textures avec
le prix betteraves c'est vraiment bon
c'est de l'autre on vraiment différent
de ce qu'on trouve sur la marché faut
s'amuser en fait avec les recettes qu'on
retrouve dans notre frigo
revenons en trempettes de l'industrie le
premier choix de notre nutritionniste va
assommer frêche moi j'ai trouvé vraiment
chouette au niveau l'avant instructive
pour le sel et aussi pour la liste
d'ingrédients qui étaient assez simples
et courtes qui avaient des produits
comme ceux qui sont je l'espère bon au
goût mais qui sont faits main stadium
mais moi ça me donne l'espoir d' autres
trompettes font bonne figure avec des
listes d'ingrédients plus simple et sans
trop d'additifs
en plus des sommes et fraîche les haras
où va fontaine santé choix du président
cuisine poirier trempette à barrett et
skotidakis
à vos crudités prêts partez
[Musique]
et